Jonathan, we have a segment called New To Drew.
It feels weird to say my name, but it rhymes.
And we love rhyming around here.
Love a rhyme.
And I'm excited, 'cause I get to learn new things,
and we get to learn something new together.
I have actually, I think I know,
I have seen this on Instagram,
and I've never been so excited in my life.
I'm an avid "Bake Off" fan.
I'm not really a good baker, but I love "Bake Off".
I love "Nailed It".
I'm more on the "Nailed It" speed,
because I can't really do it,
but I'm really excited to be here, don't be scared.
Don't you and your husband also love "British Bake Off"
Love "Bake Off".
I'm obsessed.
Yeah.
Okay, well we're gonna make a tsunami cake,
and here to teach us how to make a tsunami cake
is the owner and CEO of Make My Cake in Harlem, New York,
please welcome
(audience applause erupts)
Aliyyah Baylor.
Drew, it's such a great moment for me to be here with you.
You've been a friend in my head since "Firestarter".
Oh, I am your friend.
(they laugh)
And I love "Firestarter".
Yes.
(Drew mimics flames roaring)
Jonathan, awesome.
Love you so much.
We have this trend that has taken over social media.
Yeah, it has.
And the great thing about it is
that it's something that is something you can do at home.
You don't have to go to a bakery and get it done.
You can do this at home.
How?
Teach us.
Well, what we've done,
and we've made it a little bit easier for you.
We've already domed the cakes,
'cause we wanna do something very cute,
with your face on it.
Oh.
Yes.
So we're gonna start with this, we're gonna,
I want you to insert right in the middle.
Jonathan.
Yes.
Yours.
And you're gonna insert and then,
and the finale is gonna be even more exciting.
So, let's mix a little, just a little,
we're gonna start with just a little,
come on, just a,
Okay, just a little bit, just a little
Like that much?
Yes.
We're gonna start with that much.
And then, spatulas everyone.
Mm-hm.
Stir and stir.
So what we have is a white chocolate ganache,
that has been loosened just a little bit
with a little bit more extra cream.
Uh-huh.
So that way (laughs)
(audience laughs)
so that way,
that the whole effect of it flowing down,
'cause usually, I don't know how many home bakers are here?
Any?
(scattered audience whoops)
Awesome.
I encourage that.
I was my mom's apprentice when I was 12.
Aw.
And we have grown our business just from,
from our apartment,
all the way to three storefronts right now.
Oh my God!
(audience applauds)
So and add in a coffee shop as well.
So you have to come up and it's called "I Like It Black".
I love that title.
I think that's brilliant.
So this is a perfect color.
Oh good.
I feel good about this.
Now the cylinder.
So this cylinder is acetate.
I'm gonna have you do it,
because I'm giving y'all instructions.
Go straight down.
All the way down.
And the key to the cylinder is that it's gonna be taped.
So you wanna make sure that it is-
I wanna shove?
You're gonna shove and don't worry about the indentation.
Oh my God, I'm so nervous.
Don't worry about, that's a good shove.
That's a good shove.
No more?
No more.
Okay.
My God, can I do it?
I'm scared.
Yes, I want you to do it.
(audience laughs)
Okay.
You're gonna push that down.
Seems like "Operation".
Yes.
(audience laughs)
You know what I'm gonna-
It is.
And then when you put the cylinder-
(audience laughs)
Look at that.
What is Drew doing?
Okay.
She's going around...
And put all the way down.
All the way down.
Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Now do you feel like it's firm?
No.
No I do.
(audience laughs)
Maybe.
Are you ready?
Yes.
So this is the part-
Oh my gosh.
Do we pour this in?
Do we pour this in there?
Yeah, so we have to make sure this is-
Oh, yeah, because you don't want any...
Oh, now I understand.
Because I've done that.
(audience laughs)
I've literally done that.
No, it's gotta be like-
This came apart, and it just
flows all over the place.
Like icing tight.
Icing tight.
Yes. So-
Can I pour it in?
Do I get to pour it in?
So what you're gonna do,
I'm feeling risky.
I'm feeling, I'm feeling good.
Don't get any on you.
Oh God.
And don't get on your...
I'm gonna help you.
Am I just pouring?
Am I just going rogue?
You wanna go around.
Around?
Oh yeah, don't get it on the person obviously.
Yes.
Go around.
Okay.
Oh God.
Okay. Keep going.
I mean, oh gosh.
Keep going.
You got a great amount.
Did we do it?
Yes.
So this is the fun part.
Get your gold spoons.
Get your gold spoon.
Okay.
Excellent.
Drew!
(audience applauds)
Are we literally cake making prodigies?
Yeah, she is.
We are doing it Jonathan.
So what sprinkles would you like?
The great thing about this is also the wow factor.
A little does a lot better.
This cake concept is all about the wow factor
and all about having fun.
Can I go buck wild?
So, yes.
Are you allowed to do one of everything?
What happens?
I think you-
I want it all.
This is what I like.
So let's-
Have you met me?
Let's go there and let's go there.
Oh shoot, okay.
But not the whole thing.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
(audience laughs)
Why not?
I don't know because-
It's gonna be too much, if you do the whole thing
Are you having such anxiety right now?
Watching us do this?
I'm human.
I feel it, I'm sorry.
I am human too much.
All right, okay.
It's like watching someone else do highlights.
I'm like, oh gosh.
(Aliyyah laughs)
(audience laughs)
I know.
All right, okay.
Now the-
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
Go for this, I wanna touch of that,
Okay.
'Cause we're ready.
Yeah.
I wanna be ready.
Because this is (laughs)
(audience laughs)
You all are not coming to the shop without supervision.
Okay, mine's so ready.
We're ready?
We ready?
Yes.
The wow part.
Are we ready?
(audience applauds)
All right.
Take both ends, like this.
Uh-huh.
Oh, it's happening?
Pull up.
Now audience, I want you to count down.
One.
Two, three. (cheers and applauds)
Oh, my stars.
This is so cute.
And fold that over.
Put it on a plate.
My little me wants to just like, yeah, there we go.
I love it!
Did we do it so good?
I think y'all did great.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
Thank you so much, Aliyyah.
It's all about the wow factor
and that's exactly what you delivered, the wow factor.
Thank you, Aliyyah, so much.
And a little bit of a mess,
but it's okay.
Well, messy and gorgeous.
Messy and gorgeous is our theme.
Yes.
Yes, exactly.
(audience applauds)
Aliyyah, thank you so much for teaching us
how to make our very own fabulous tsunami cake,
and Jonathan, again,
(audience laughs)
I love your book so much.
"Love That Story", it is available now.
(bright theme music)